kennt brief ich kann nicht atmen das
waren die letzten worte von george freut
nachdem ein weißer polizist minute lang
um genau zu sein acht minuten und 46
sekunden auf feuz nackten knete doch
diese worte sind nicht erst seit diesem
gewaltsamen tod die parole für den kampf
gegen rassismus und polizeigewalt in den
usa
denn bereits 2014 starb erica in new
york durch polizeigewalt auch seine
letzten worte waren erkennt brief ich
kann nicht atmen nun zugeschaltet
schwierige tage für die familie von
george freut wie hart ist dieser tag für
die familie
es wird mich zurück ins jahr 2014 als
wir mit etwas ähnlichem umgehen mussten
ich hoffe einfach dass sie etwas frieden
finden und die ganze welt steht ihnen
bei das haben die last two weeks in den
vergangenen zwei wochen ist viel
passiert
polizisten die am mord von beteiligt
waren und sind alle angeklagt die
polizei bekommt weniger geld an glaubens
und das ist jetzt muss einfach verändert
ich gesagt glaube ich das
immer noch bei dem die tötung durch
einen würgegriff betrifft die jetzt in
new york das online auszuweiten
die proteste der letzten zwei wochen
oder die aufstände feier des lebens
finden sie das jetzt durch die polizei
gegeben